we actually have some breaking news
right now coming from the White House
which just announced details of the
president's upcoming summit with Russian
President Vladimir Putin major Garrett
is at the White House with those details
major good morning a tookie-tookie
details Nora July 16th
that's the date the location Helsinki
Finland the announcement coming in
coordination this White House and the
Kremlin hitting send if you will on the
paper statement simultaneously
announcing it to the world President
Trump has wanted to put this sum
together for a while John Bolton the
national security adviser met with
Vladimir Putin earlier this week to set
the final details for it yesterday given
an opportunity to talk about their
issues he intends to discuss the
president left out Russian meddling in
the 2016 election and fears that it
might be doing the same thing in 2018
this morning he tweeted Russia continues
to deny that that's true with the US
intelligence community does not deny it
the US intelligence community has said
over and over Russia did attempt a medal
of 2016 election and this is an
opportunity if the president takes it to
drive that issue in his face-to-face
meeting with Vladimir Putin will see in
Helsinki if that happens a big summit
ahead major thank you for bringing us
that breaking news